- Please allow me to introduce myself.
I'm a man of wealth and taste.
I been around a long, long year.
Stole many man's soul and fate.
I was around when Jesus had
his moment of doubt and pain.
I made damn sure Pilate washed his hands
and sealed his faith.
Pleased to meet you,
hope you guess my name.
Loving you is the nature of my game.
I hung around St. Petersburg
when I thought it was time for a change.
I killed the tsar and the ministers.
Pleased to meet you,
hope you guess my name.
Lovin' you is the nature of my game.
- [Mark] All right, Timothy.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Timothy, where
are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- [Timothy] Chicago, Illinois.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- [Timothy] Yes, my dad
was Chicago police officer.
He was honest and upright
and he was a heavy drinker of alcohol
but he could handle it.
And, you know, he got shot
three times with an M14
by a maniac who got committed
to the nut house for life.
'Cause the guy just, every
week, he just shot somebody.
The guy was nuts so they committed
him to the mental asylum.
- [Mark] Wow.
And when he got shot,
he made me throw away three
prescription bottles of pill,
and I guess they were pain pills.
And he used Jack Daniel's
and vodka to kill the pain.
That's what he did do.
- [Mark] Interesting.
- Great man though.
- [Mark] So your childhood was good?
- Yes, it wasn't bad at all.
- [Mark] And after you
left your parents house,
where did you go then?
- To Phoenix, Arizona.
- [Mark] And how was Phoenix?
- Too hot for me.
130 degrees every day
and then at night, 138 or 140.
The sun goes down it gets hotter.
If you're not born there,
you can't get used to it.
- [Mark] Wow.
So were drugs a part of your life?
- No, not until I got to high school.
And then there was all kinds of drugs.
- Yeah.
- And, you know,
you had to go to a bad
neighborhood to get 'em.
And, you know, there was
fun drugs like mescaline,
pink organic mescaline in a capsule,
two dollars, for a pill.
And you'd just sit there
and you see colors and you're happy.
Yeah, you're seein'
colors and you're happy.
It's not that bad.
- [Mark] Right.
- You're not scared,
you're not seein' monsters
or anything like that,
you're just seein' colors.
And you got a body high so
for two bucks it wasn't bad.
- [Mark] And how about today?
Are you still using anything?
- No, I don't use anything.
- [Mark] You drink though?
- I do, I drink beer
- Yeah.
- I like vodka once in
awhile but not every day.
See, when I lived in Phoenix,
they have a place called
local alcohol reception center
and the police bring 'em in
if they find street drugs,
but you can go there yourself
and they give you Librium.
And Librium is lesser than Valium.
I worked at Eli Lilly
drug company in Chicago
and I thought, "I'm gonna
have access to drugs now,"
and that was not the scene.
But it paid good and they
gave me a company car.
And a Standard gas station
credit card, they gave it to me.
So that wasn't bad.
A Chevy Malibu.
Station wagon, burgundy.
- [Mark] What jobs have you
had throughout your career?
- Telemarketing, that's what I do.
LA Times, Orange County
edition that taught me.
And then I went to mortgages.
I went to Mission Priority Lending.
I went to some other company, I can't, oh,
Howard Wheel Labow and Fredrickson.
- [Mark] So you sell loans
or whatever over the phone?
- Over the phone.
- Yeah.
- That's all I did, over-the-phone work.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 64.
- [Mark] 64.
- Born, 4, 11, 55.
Well, 65, come April.
And April's right around the corner.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So, you live in LA now.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And were you ever married?
- No.
- [Mark] Never married, no kids?
- No married, no kids.
- [Mark] No kids.
And sometimes you'll come
down here to skid row
and pick up some ladies.
- Oh, yeah.
Like, whenever I can.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] How often is that?
- Whenever I feel like it
and I feel like it every day.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So, you're here
multiple times a week.
- Yes, multiple times a week.
- [Mark] Yep, and you have
picked different women
that you'll pick up or?
- Different ones, yeah.
I know the good ones, I can look at 'em
and see what's happening.
- [Mark] Right.
Where will you guys go?
- We go to a motel.
We'll talk first, and you
know, get to meet each other,
and then I'll take her out
for whatever she wants to do.
Eat, if she wants to eat,
I'll take her for food.
Dinner, breakfast, lunch,
whatever she wants.
- [Mark] And you'll spend the
night her or just a little?
- I usually go a to Motel
6 'cause it's affordable.
It's cheaper.
- [Mark] Yeah, very cheap.
- I can't afford $100 for one day,
$100 a night.
- Yeah.
- When Motel 6 is 40 bucks,
you get day and night,
that's not bad.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So, you're doing oral sex or intercourse
or what kind of stuff?
- [Timothy] Well, she does oral sex on me
and then intercourse, you know.
- [Mark] Are you using
condoms when you do this?
- [Timothy] Oh yeah,
nowadays you need a condom,
because you never know
what the hell they got.
Once I get to know her, if I
know her for a month or so,
then I know her, then
I don't need a condom,
'cause I know she's not fuckin' around.
She's not doin' nobody else.
- [Mark] Yeah, what's the
price range for these services?
What's the most and what's the least?
- [Timothy] Oh, you know,
for the knock-out babe.
You know, from home, born
and raised in Chicago,
knock-out babes on Rush Street,
they want crack, they wanna smoke crack,
they wanna snort crack,
they wanna snort coke,
those kind of ladies.
And they want money and those are $500
and you gotta have the money
or they ain't goin' with ya.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And $500 and then ya gotta get a motel.
And they wanna nice motel.
They want the fuckin' Palmer
House in downtown Chicago,
which is $275 a night.
A day and night, $275 plus tax.
That's kind of steep.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And what's the low end of the range?
- The low end is Motel 6.
- [Mark] And what about the girls.
What's the least a girl
has charged for this?
- The least, 20 bucks.
- [Mark] 20 bucks.
- 'Cause she, as bad as I
want it, she wants it too
and she's clean though.
- Yeah.
- She's not a ho on the street.
She's not fucking a 197 guys every day.
- Yeah.
- You know?
She's a good woman,
she's just a sexologist.
(Mark laughs)
She wants it every day too.
- [Mark] Do you prefer this lifestyle
where you have your choice
of female every night
or being married?
- I prefer choice of females.
I'd like to get married too, you know.
I don't think there's nothin'
wrong with having kids
and raise a family.
That's a beautiful thing.
- [Mark] Have you had
relationships with women
that are not working street?
- Yeah, I have, I have.
- [Mark] And how have those been?
- They went very good.
- Yeah.
So, a lot of the women that you'll pick up
are addicted to drugs.
- Some are.
- Yeah.
- If they are, I know danger.
If they're crack heads or somethin',
that the one thing they want,
they don't give a fuck about you.
They want that rock of crack.
That's what they really want.
- [Mark] Have you been
robbed before by them?
- No, I've never been robbed, never.
I was in the Marine Corps eight years
so I can pretty well handle myself
in any kind of physical situation.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But, you know, when I meet a woman,
I can read her real quick.
If she's a dope addict,
danger signs come up for me.
'Cause, if she's using dope,
she's fuckin' around with every
other swingin' dick in town.
And she's probably got some
kind of disease or somethin'.
Who knows, but I figure it out.
- [Mark] All right, well Timothy,
thank you so much for talking
with me and being so open
and good luck with everything from here.
- Yeah, let's go get some beer now.
- [Mark] Let's go get you some beer, man.
- All right, let's go.
- All right, thanks.
- You gotta show me where this place is at
'cause I don't actually know.
- [Mark] Yeah, there's
actually two places.